hey guys my name is Jeff it is the
fourth of August and here's the things
that mattered in gaming today activision
blizzard announced the financial results
for their second fiscal quarter and
given they're responsible for overwatch
things are going pretty well that
revenue was a record 1.5 7 billion which
is a very big number and a fifty percent
increase over the same period last year
across all of its properties the company
reported 491 million monthly active
users during the quarter 409 million of
which were playing candy crush which
Activision Blizzard acquired only three
million of those were from Blizzard
games like overwatch hearthstone and
world warcraft the company also revealed
that overwatch is now attracted more
than 15 million players globally
quakecon kicked off today and with it
has come the first gameplay trailer from
prey the trailer features the main
character Morgan you exploring a space
station gun in hand and encountering all
sorts of creepy crawlies and shadowy
beasts a video also hints at the game's
story as Morgan says he feels like
someone is watching him that does this
description breeds arcane reimagines
this franchise from the ground up with
an added psychological twist in pray
you're the first human enhanced with
alien powers aboard a desolate space
station under assault improvise and
innovate in order to survive as you
search for answers finally take tear
drop some knowledge about their plans in
their sales report today that revenue
was reported at three hundred and eleven
point six million up thirteen percent
from last year and take to identify GTA
5 GTA online
NBA 2k16 and battle born as the main
contributors CEO Strauss Zelnick did add
that baton Warren didn't perform as well
as expected the GTA online posted record
numbers take two also revealed that the
console versions of XCOM 2 has been
delayed slightly and will now arrive
three days later on sep tember 30 on top
of that the company said rockstar games
also is hard at work on some exciting
future projects that will be revealed
soon sup by gamespot for more news from
quite calmly beautiful on today's
stories and I will see you again
tomorrow